les journées du patrimoine partout en
france avec l'ouverture de sites
exceptionnels pour lequel jean c'est le
cas du conservatoire d'anatomie de la
faculté de montpellier qui est
accessible au public une fois par an une
exploration du corps humain véronique
guillaume françois mazou s'il est un
lieu loin du soleil loin des
palpitations de la vie extérieure c'est
bien celui ci
le musée de la demie les personnes qui
viennent
un écorché montre le chemin
et là où on se retrouve bien dépouillé
mise à nu explorer disséquer face à une
face cachée qu'on ne saurait voir
ça n'était pas musée des horreurs non
madame
oui carrément sachant que forcément mai
je pense que va pas aussi apprendre la
tolérance comment ça peut exister des
trucs comme ça quoi également que jean
les punir et de l'épongé fait exploser
comme gran franche est passé bien une
seule fois par an ils sortent des
armoires de l'oubli pourtant pendant des
siècles ils ont été objet d'étude pièces
de concours observé dessinée manipulé
par de jeunes carabins
c'est une collection unique 5600 pièce
classée monument historique
ce sont des pièces qui n'ont plus
d'usagers mais qui sourire et
reproductibles qui font partie du
patrimoine et qui sont le reflet de neuf
siècles d'enseignement de la médecine
donc c'est un devoir de mémoire revient
aussi aux plantations du concret du
matériel est presque aussi bien pour les
étudiants que pour des personnes qui
souhaitent aller visiter ce lac a même
une autre image notre présentation donc
que simplement de voir sur un écran
d'ordinateur telle ou telle pièce du
corps humain syphilis bubons honteux et
il servait n'ai rien aujourd'hui la
collection est malade de bactéries et me
cause qu'ils attaquent les craint lui
aussi se dégrade alors dans la tente
d'être restaurée cette année encore le
conservatoire va fermer